le recteur de martiniquais dans son
caddie ce matin pascal fons dans ce
studio quelques jours à peine après sa
nomination chez nous il ya pleine
contestation contre les suppressions de
postes et de classes
pascal jean bonjour je vends béatrice
cormier auparavant votre prédécesseur
vaut aujourd'hui vous avez déjà tout dit
pour justifier ces suppressions mais vos
explications syndicats enseignants
parents d'élèves n'en veulent pas alors
que faisons nous tout d'abord le
dialogue social a été noué dès mon
arrivée avec les syndicats et demain
puisque vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
dans vos journaux
donc l'établissement père et non je
recevrai les parents d'élèves donc le
dialogue social est entamée parce que
disait de trois semaines oui oui c'est
pas les deux les parents d'élèves les
enseignants et les notaires mais le
dialogue social il est là j'ai reçu ou
mon corps mon cabinet lorsque je pouvais
pas être disponibles
les responsables des établissements plus
également les responsables syndicaux des
fédérations donc le dialogue
il est là et à l'occasion de chaque de
chaque rencontre de chaque entretien
nourrit ses on discute effectivement des
problèmes de postes puisque c'est de
cela dont il s'agit mais tout a déjà été
dit mais tout a déjà été dit non
seulement ils ne veulent pas oui sauf
qu'il ya une réalité cette réalité c'est
une baisse démographique même s'ils
veulent pas entendre ses arguments c'est
une c'est une réalité
l'autre réalité c'est que si on
appliquait strictement en réalité le
ratio on serait pas à -16 que -116 comme
j'ai entendu leur masse - 163 postes
donc il ya une réalité il faut en tenir
compte j'ajoute par ailleurs parce que
souvent ce n'est pas dit mais que deux
parmi les priorités nationales
il y a précisément la maîtrise des
fondamentaux et notamment une action
précise sur l'école primaire et sur
cette école primaire sur le premier
degré on a créé 11 postes
justement les syndicats disent que
l'action n'est pas suffisantes
concernant ces jeunes en difficulté
parce qu'à écouter la martinique est en
crise et que par exemple illettrisme il
ya encore trop de cas écoutez moi je
prends une situation telle que telle
qu'elle est
le gouvernement a mis en place un
certain nombre de dispositifs dont le
dédoublement des cp et ce1
on ne peut pas avoir les résultats du
jour au lendemain simplement il va
falloir attendre un an ou deux ans
effectivement c'est cette politique là
qu'il faut suivre même amplifiée en
réalité je suis à l'étude pour voir dans
quelle mesure on peut davantage
amplifier cette cette aide aux enfants
en difficulté le but encore une fois est
temps que chaque élève dès le cp en
réalité maîtriser les fondamentaux
jusqu'au cm2 et en solex et des moyens
humains et donc déclamer les moyens
humains il faut toujours des moyens
humains si demain on me donne 100 postes
je serai le premier
le premier est évidemment heureux donc
les moyens humains
c'est une chose l'encadrement des
adultes c'est également un élément
important mais on peut très bien par des
méthodes pédagogiques innovants il
suffit de regarder ce qui se passe dans
les cp des doublés voir comment les
maîtres et les maîtresses organisent
leur classe pour voir deux insistent sur
ce point pour voir comment on peut aussi
même lorsqu'on a des classes j'allais
dire non pas surchargé mais en tout cas
avec un certain nombre d'élèves comment
on peut améliorer la pédagogie donc vous
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure vous avez
parlé ou en tout cas dans vos dans vos
journaux de 28 élèves en moyenne mais il
faut quand même dire aussi cette réalité
c'est que même si on peut ne pas s'en
satisfaire
c'est que les résultats en martinique de
moyenne d'élèves par classe sont en
dessous de la moyenne
ça ne satisfait pas les parents d'élèves
ne va rester sur va camper sur ses
positions parce qu'elle joue c'est pas
une question de camper sur ses positions
je l'abordé elle va enfler mais la
mobilisation à l'amflora de toute façon
les résultats on ne peut de toute façon
se prononcer des victimes en qu'au moins
de juin lorsque nous en au rectorat on
aura les effectifs réels pour le moment
on n'a pas les effectifs réels
alors vous parlez de de pertes
démographiques pour la martinique
lamartine et qui perd sa jeunesse qui
perd ses élèves
mais pourquoi ne pas le dire carrément
est ce que ça vaut encore le coup de
construire ce lycée schoelcher puisque
on sait qu'à moyen terme à long terme
cet établissement ne pourra pas
accueillir autant d'élèves pour lequel
sera prévu la question du lycée show
cher c'est une question qui est qui
concerne évidemment l'éducation mais
également la collectivité territoriale
puisque passer une loi la loi voilà la
lie à une histoire il ya un passé
particulier la situation et que ce que
ce lycée a été a été construit donc
c'est une réalité on va pas on va pas
arrêter
évidemment le projet mais plus
généralement au delà du lycée schoelcher
on peut par exemple s'interroger sur
lorsque dans une commune en a trois
collèges par exemple on ne peut séduire
au vernet qui leur plaît on peut
s'interroger savoir s'il n'y a pas
nécessité par de fusionner deux collèges
pour dégager d'ailleurs des moyens voilà
donc je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre
de réflexions que je vais mener que le
président de la ctm sur ces questions
toutes ces questions c'est bien
chronophage ses biens énergivores ya
pourtant d'autres dossiers par exemple
l'accent sur parcours super puisque
demain ce sera la limite pour les
inscriptions post bac ça fonctionne bien
parcours celui-ci très bien on est très
au dessus des chiffres de la menace ya
là on est à peu près 95% 94 % d'élèves
d'élèves de terminale inscrits sur
parcours sur le problème c'est pas tant
d'ailleurs le nombre des élèves qui sont
inscrits que la manière dont ils l'ont
fait serge profite de cette occasion
pour dire absolument aux élèves et aux
parents de d'amplifier ce mouvement ce
que beaucoup on en fait qu'un voeu où on
fait plusieurs voeux mais dans les
filières sélectives en fait il faut
faire plusieurs voeux dont certains en
matière non sélective donc ça c'est
important parce que la commission que je
que je dirigerai à partir du mois de mai
ce seront permettront en orientera aussi
les élèves en fonction des voeux qui ont
été émis et de la motivation puisque à
partir du 14 jusqu'au 31 et à la
motivation qui est extrêmement
importante parce qu'elle joue est
arrivée en martinique il y a trois
semaines dans une académie qui a vu
passer avant vous une rectrice dont la
réputation était d'avoir quand même
serré les boulons gommer certaines
dérives financières au point de même
apporté plein quand il y avait eu des
abus et il y en a eu
bref elle a secoué le bâtiment de
terville poursuivez-vous cette fois
absolument je crois que la
rationalisation et la bonne santé
financière en tout cas des finances de
l'éducation est une condition pour avoir
des marges de manoeuvre si effectivement
il ya des dérives financières mais le
mât prédécesseur a mis en place tout un
dispositif pour justement encadrer ces
dérives et j'allais dire remonter la
pente ce qu'elle a fait est que je
poursuivrai évidemment avec avec énergie
mais dans le but il faut bien le
comprendre
au delà de la bonne gestion c'est aussi
dégager des marges de manoeuvre
financières pour soutenir des projets
pour amplifier certains projets qui me
tiennent par exemple à coeur c'est le
plan anglais l'employabilité la priorité
que j'accorde mois la voie
professionnelle je pense que c'est
extrêmement important et notamment un
projet qui verra peut-être le jour c'est
un erasmus caribéen qui est fondamental
pour revenir au bâtiment de thierville
faut faire comprendre que cette académie
que le rectorat a une mission de service
public mobiliser les troupes
ça aussi c'est important au sein du
rectorat
oui bien sûr je pense que tout le tous
les membres va tous les tout le
personnel du rectorat
en tout cas de l'encadrement ils tous
les services sont mobilisés sur sur un
même objectif c'est que les politiques
éducatives réussi ce que les élèves
soient bien formés et trouve à terme
évidemment un emploi de limiter autant
que faire se peut les décrocheurs est ce
que c'est ça aussi la réalité
donc tout le rectorat et tous les
personnels de l'éducation générale de
cette académie sont mobilisés sur cet
objectif soit légalement et voir avec
les autres partenaires peuvent par
exemple les politiques ou bien
l'université un petit peu également
comment fixer cette jeunesse
martiniquaise ou qu'elle reste en
martinique où près je revienne en tout
cas je crois qu'il faut avoir un plan à
long terme dont je verrai certainement
pas les résultats
c'est à dire un plan à long terme c'est
se poser les bonnes questions qu'est-ce
qui fonctionne qu'est ce qui ne marche
pas de quoi a besoin en fait ce
territoire et ça ça passe notamment par
une expertise en tout cas un état des
lieux
des filières qui non seulement
fonctionnent mais qui sont appelées à se
développer
donc je vais prendre un exemple c'est le
les services et l'aide à la personne par
exemple avec le vieillissement de la
population
c'est le tourisme et le nautisme donc je
crois qu'il ya des actions concrètes à
faire en ce domaine mais ça demande
évidemment de la maîtrise des
fondamentaux l'anglais et une bonne
formation au niveau professionnel
un autre dossier qui alimente
l'actualité le dossier du sert et demi
un dossier qui crispe quel est votre
positionnement rappelle que vous êtes
chancelier de cette université des
antilles alors c'est un dossier
extrêmement complexe dont je suis en
train de prendre la mesure
évidemment il ya un certain nombre de
dossiers je reçois très prochainement la
vice présidente du pôle particuliers
donc j'évoquerai ça avec elle
ce qui est certain c'est que il faut
absolument éviter que l'université
antilles gers disloque
on a déjà perdu la guyane ça c'est un
premier point et ensuite avec mon
collègue de la guadeloupe donc le
recteur de guadeloupe
on essaiera de mener une action commune
et cohérente afin de préserver en
réalité le paul driot rites et absolue à
c'est une priorité dans les dossiers
effectivement donc plongé en charge tout
simplement parce qu'on ne peut pas se
permettre un effondrement de la filière
universitaire en martinique c'est cela
cela va de soi mais ça demande peut-être
également de réfléchir sur une tête des
orientations à partager avec le pot le
guadeloupéen il recadre et peut-être
certaines personnes mais recadrer je
sais pas si vous faites allusion au
président de l'université mais chacun
son rôle chacun selon ses compétences
mais ça n'empêche pas le dialogue et
peut-être aussi le réajustement sur les
priorités affichées à l'université merci
d'avoir été ce matin avec nous parce
qu'elle jean rappelle que vous êtes le
recteur de l'académie de martinique
merci d'avoir été dans son caddie bonne
journée merci
[Musique]